the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today's lecture is not mathematically
hard but it's really important to
establish vocabulary today we're going
to talk about vibration for the rest of
the term and vibration is essentially
applied dynamics so up until now we've
been finding equations of motion but not
solving them did you notice that we have
I've almost never asked you to [ __ ] you
know solve the equation of motion that
you've just discovered using Lagrange or
whatever the rest of the term we're
actually going to be talking mostly
about the resulting motion the equations
of motion are pretty easy to find you
have all the techniques that you need to
know for finding and now we're going to
talk about how things vibrate so why do
we choose vibration vibrations one is a
is an incredibly common phenomenon we
wouldn't have speech without vibration
you wouldn't have musical instruments
without vibration you it's a positive
thing when it's making good music it's a
negative thing when it's keeping you
awake at night because the air
conditioner in the next room is causing
something to rattle in the room and it's
driving you nuts so it's good it can be
you can want it it can be desirable and
you cannot want it and you need to know
ways of getting rid of it
and so we're going to talk about
vibration about making vibration about
suppressing vibration about isolating
sensitive instruments from the vibration
of the floor things like that so that's
the topic of the rest of the term and
today we're going to talk about single
degree of freedom systems and you might
you're you might think that we're
spending an awful lot of time on single
degree freedom systems but there's
actually there's a reason for that lots
of things in real life like this is just
an aluminum rod this this will vibrate
and continuous systems which this is
having theoretically infinite number of
degrees of freedom yet when it comes to
talking about its vibration it is
conceptually easy to think about the
vibration of an object like this one
natural frequency one natural mode at a
time and in fact you can model that
natural mode with its equal single
degree of freedom equivalent and that's
the way I approach vibration so if you
can isolate one particular mode you can
literally model it as a mass spring
dashpot so you need to understand the
mass spring dashpot behavior inside and
out okay because we're going to use its
the vocabulary we use to just to do much
more complicated things so single degree
freedom system you know like the simple
pendulum has a natural frequency in this
case has a mode shape here's an here's
another one kind of fun single degree
freedom this obviously involves rotation
and you can figure that out using
LeGrande or whatever single degree
freedom systems but now I'm going to
excite one mode of vibration of this
here the real high pitch get it down
here by the mic so the people at home
can hear it by two kilohertz way up
there and that's one natural mode of
this thing in longitudinal vibration
when I thump it sideways you hear a
lower tone hear that mmm
Robin that's bending vibration of this
thing but each mode of vibration I can
think of by it's in terms of its
equivalent single degree freedom
oscillator so we'll get to talking about
these things a little bit continuous
systems in the last couple lectures of
the term but for today then we're really
going to develop this vocabulary around
the vibration of single degree freedom
systems so let's start
all right so to keep it from being
totally boring I'm going to start with a
little mass spring dashpot that has two
Springs and they're of such a length
that unstretched there they just meet in
the middle and then I'm going to take a
mass and I'm going to squeeze it in
between these two Springs can't draw
spring very well today and this is K 1
and this is K 2 and here's M then we'll
put it on roller so it's obviously
constrained to motion in one direction
and I'll pick this point here as the
place I'm going to put my inertial
coordinate so my inertial coordinate be
where the end points of these two
Springs were now this squeezes spring in
here I have this clearly pre is pre
compression in these Springs so there is
we are no longer in a 0 for state right
so and I want to get the equations of
motion this and moreover I want to
predict I want to find out what's the
natural frequency of this spring so
let's check here let's check your
intuition so write down on your piece of
paper whether or not the natural
frequency will be different because
there's pre compression or whether or
not that pre compression in the springs
has nothing to do with the natural
frequency to write down on your paper
natural frequency is different our
natural frequency is the same this is
how come our Givens have a prediction
here
and then we'll set about figuring this
out and in the course of doing it will
develop a little vocabulary we've all
through the course so far when we've
done equations of motion we've usually
picked you know the zero spring force
position and we sort of led you down
this rosy path that suggests you know
that's the way we do it but there are
other other ways that you're going to
find that are preferable to that
sometimes so that's one of the reasons
I'm doing this example so let's do a
free body diagram and if I held this
mass for example right at the center
when I put the springs in it's obvious
that this spring gets compressed by half
of the length of the mass and this
spring gets compressed by half at the
link of the mass right so this is going
to be L long so if I held it right in
the middle it would compress L over 2
and L over 2 but then when I release it
if these Springs are of different spring
constant it's going to move a little bit
so the force on this side pushing back
is some k1 times L over 2 minus the
distance that I move in that direction
which would relieve it and the force on
this side also pushes back its K 2 times
L 2 over 2 plus X because when I go in
that direction I'm compressing it even
further and those are the total forces
in the X direction on this body there's
an N and an mg which we know we don't
have to deal with because we're only
interested in motion left and right all
right so we can say some of the forces
in the X Direction mass times the
acceleration and those forces are
k1l 2 - X - K - L over 2 + X and that's
the complete equation of motion for this
problem and rearrange it so that I get
the functions of X together here so MX
double dot plus k1 plus k2 times x
equals L over 2 times k1 minus k2 and
that's your equation of motion
it's non-homogeneous this is all
constants on the right hand side and on
the left hand sides are the functions of
X stuff its functions of X right so
what's the natural frequency of the
system
I hear us square root of the quantity k1
plus k2 the stiffness divided by M you
know K over m usual mass spring dashpot
system did the pre-compression have
anything to do with the natural
frequency I want to ask you to embarrass
yourselves but a few of you probably got
that wrong right so there's a lesson in
this we read that I want you to go away
with and we'll go and I'll say it once
and that is when an external force it
has nothing to do with the motion
coordinates in the problem it doesn't
affect the natural frequency does this
it either external ease come from
external forces these are these pre
compressions right and I can separate
them out and they are not functions of X
the stuff on the on the right-hand side
of the equation that's not function that
the motion variable did not cannot
affect the natural frequency okay so I
should give you another one this is our
common thing hanging from a stick I've
taken my system that I built the other
day for a different purpose but now it's
just a mass hanging from a spring and
it's right now at its equilibrium
position are the forces and there's a
net there's nonzero force in the spring
clearly has a natural frequency and it's
that natural frequency a function of
gravity and so if you go to write the
equations of motion of this system you
know you would find MX double dot plus
k x equals mg but the mg has not a
function of X and natural frequencies of
getting square root of K over m okay now
we want to talk about the solving this
differential equation and because it's
got this constant term on the right hand
side it's non-homogeneous which is kind
of a nuisance term in terms of dealing
with the differential equation be a lot
nicer at the right-hand side were zero
so I want to make this the right-hand
side of this one zero and that's a
drokken useable conclusion from that
first thing I need to know is I'd like
to know what is the static equilibrium
position of this and when you go to
compute static equilibrium you look at
the equation of motion and say make all
motion variables things that are
functions of time zero so no
acceleration you're left with this so
you just solve this for whatever the
value of x is and I'll call it X sub s
for X static and you'll find that oh
well it's that term divided by k1 plus
k2 k1 minus k2 all over k1 plus k2 and
that's the static position
so now let's let's say oh well are we
started off with this motion variable
that was arbitrarily defined at the at
the middle and let's say that well it's
made up of a static component which is a
constant just a value plus a dynamic
component I'll call X sub D which moves
this is the function of time this is a
constant it's not a function of time and
that means if I take its derivative and
it might need a value for X dot that
goes away
it's just XD dot and X double dot is XD
double dot and let's substitute this in
to my equation of motion so it becomes m
XD double dot plus k1 plus k2 times and
now this term has got two pieces now x
XD plus k1 plus k2 times X s equals L
over 2 k1 minus k2 all right now if I
say well let's examine the static case
then this goes away for the static
equilibrium case this term is 0 this
term is 0 because the dynamic motion is
0 in the static case this is motion
about done that XD is motion about the
static equilibrium position so for
static case these two terms go away and
we know that this equals that but if
that's true we can get rid of this they
cancel on that these terms cancel and
I'm left with
MXD double dot plus K equivalent I'll
call it X D equals zero so the K
equivalent just the total stiffnesses in
the system whatever it works out right
in this case it's k1 plus k2 and the
natural frequency Omega n is the square
root of cake will not divided by M so
most often when you're doing if you're
interested in vibration you're
interested in natural frequencies you're
interested in solving the differential
equation you will find it advantageous
to write your equations of motion around
the around the static equilibrium
position so I could have started this
problem by saying whatever the static
equilibrium position is of this thing
that's what I'm measuring X from and
then I would have me I would have come
to this equation eventually you'd have
to figure out what is a static
equilibrium position and know what
you're doing but once you know it then
you have the answer now the same thing
is true of that problem that's a
non-homogeneous differential equation
for the for the hanging mass and we
derived the equations of motion things
for this many different ways this term
right but we easily said zero spring
force but now if you started from here
and said this is the static equilibrium
position what's the motion about this
position then you'd get the equation
with zero on the right hand side lots of
advantages are to use it
okay once first all all single degree of
freedom oscillators will boil down to
this equation this is one involving
translation but for a simple pendulum
this object for example is a pendulum
but it's you know it's a rotational so
it's a pendulum but it's one degree of
freedom all pendulum problems if you do
them about equilibrium positions boil
down to some I with respect to the point
that they're rocking about theta double
dot plus some K T torsional spring
constant theta equals zero they take the
same form so all translational single
degree freedom systems all rotational
single degree freedom system it's the
same differential equation just this
involves mass and linear acceleration
this involves mass moment of inertia and
rotational acceleration so everything
that I said what did I say about the
solution to single degree freedom
systems applies to both types of
problems
so let's look let's look into the
solution of this equation briefly
mostly I'm doing this to establish some
terminology so the solution a solution I
know or I can show that X D of T the
solution to this problem notice are
there any external forces by the
excitations f of T's or anything no so
this thing is no external excitation
it's going to make it move so it's only
source of vibration or motion is what
comes from I here in neutral conditions
right you have to do something to
perturb it and then it will and it will
vibrate so here it is it's about in
about its equilibrium position I give it
an initial deflection and let go or it's
around its initial condition and I give
it an initial velocity it also responds
or some combination to two so initial
conditions are the only things that
account for motion of something without
external excitation and that motion I
can I can write that solution as a a
cosine Omega T you'll find is this is a
possible solution B sine Omega T's and
other possible solution some a cosine
Omega t minus phase angles also solution
and some a e to the I Omega T and you
find is also solution any of those
things you can throw in and the precise
values of these things a is the bees the
fees and so forth depend on the initial
conditions okay so let's do this one
quickly
and I'll choose and I'm going to stop
writing the S sub D here this is now my
position from the equilibrium point so X
of T I'm going to say let it be and a1
cosine Omega T plus a b1 sine Omega T
and plug it in when I plug it into the
into the equation of motion X double dot
requires you take two derivatives of
each of these terms two derivatives of
cosine gives you minus Omega cosine two
derivative sine - excuse me - Omega
squared cosine minus Omega squared sine
so the answer comes out - M Omega
squared plus K equivalent here times a1
cosine plus v1 sine Omega T's obviously
in them equals zero so I've just plugged
it into that equation of motion I get
this back this is what I started with
that's X in general it is not equal to
zero
can take on any sorts all sorts of
values so that's itthat's not generally
zero and that means this must be and
from this then when we solve this we
find that Omega what we call N squared
is K over m and that's of course where
our natural frequency comes from this is
called the unn
natural frequency there's no damping in
this problem yet we get the square root
of K over m is the natural frequency of
the system okay let's find out but what
are a 1 and B 1 well at let's let X not
be X at T equals 0 here we just plug
that in here put T equals 0 here cosine
goes to 1 this term goes away so this
implies that a 1 equals X naught so we
find out right away that the a 1 cosine
Omega T takes care of the response to an
initial deflection and we need a X dot
here minus a 1 Omega sine Omega T plus B
1 Omega cosine Omega T that's the
derivative of X we know the solutions
that so it's first derivative the
velocity must look like this and let's
let V naught equals x dot at T equals 0
when we plug that in this term goes away
and we get B 1 Omega and cosine is 1 so
therefore B 1 is v-0 over Omega but in
fact the Omega is omega n because that's
it's that we already found out that
they're only only frequency that
satisfies the equation of motion when
you have only initial conditions in the
system the only frequency that is
allowed in the answer is the natural
frequency so
and we now know b1 is V naught over
Omega N and a1 is X naught so if I give
you any combination of initial
displacement and initial velocity you
can write out for me the exact time
history of the motion X naught cosine
Omega T plus V naught over Omega n sine
Omega T is a complete solution for a
response to initial conditions
so any translational oscillator one
degree of freedom
where you have a translational
coordinate measured from its equilibrium
position has the equation of motion
actually we could write you could you've
done this enough but if we added a force
here and we added some damping and I
wanted the equation of motion of this
you know that it's M X double dot plus
BX dot plus KX equals f of T and so
you'll often you know you're going to be
confronted with problems find the
equation of motion system it comes up
looking like that they say what's the
natural frequency I've been a little
sloppy I really mean what's the undamped
natural frequency and so to find the
undamped when one says that what's the
undamped natural frequency you just
temporarily let B and F be zero
just temporarily and solve then for Meg
N equals square root of K over m it's
what you do and then so we know this is
a parameter that helps that tells us
about the behavior of the system which
we always want to know for these single
rear freedom systems what is the natural
frequency of the system okay
and we know for B equals zero and F of
zero then the response can be only due
to initial conditions so we have X of T
we know is going to be some code X
naught cosine mega n P plus V 0 over a
mega n sine Omega n T and every simple
vibration system in the world behaves
basically like this from initial
condition so be some part responding to
the initial displacement some parts of
the initial velocity and damping is
going to going to make it a little bit
more complex but not actually by much
the same basic terms appear even when
you have damping in it this can be
expressed as some a cosine Omega in this
case n t minus a phase angle and it's
useful to know this trigonometric
identity to be able to put things
together into an expression like that
and you'll find out that a let's say is
just the square root of the two pieces
it's a sine and cosine term so you have
an X nought squared plus a B 0 over
Omega N squared square root
remember this is any a and B it's just a
square root of a squared plus B squared
that's what we're doing here and the
phase angle the tangent inverse if this
were been calling this like an a and
this is the B quantity it's a tangent
inverse of my signs right B over a which
in this case then is
tangent inverse of X be 0 over X naught
Omega n that's always to it and finally
another trig thing that you need to know
we're going to use it quite a bit is
that if you have an expression a cosine
Omega t minus V that's equal to the real
part of a e to the I Omega T ok and if a
is real and I don't want to write it
that way when a is real then this is
just the real it's just the real part
it's a times e to the I Omega t minus B
because Euler's formula says e to the I
theta equals cosine theta plus I sine of
theta so if you have an I Omega t minus
V here you get back a cosine Omega t
minus C and another term and I sine
Omega t minus V so you can always
express that as the real part of that so
we're going to need that little trig
identity as we go through the term now I
found
in many years of teaching vibration that
one is something that for some that many
students find a little confusing is this
notion of phase angle this phase angle
really means so there's a trial try to
explain it to you in a couple different
ways so let's look at what this
vibration that we're talking about here
X naught cosine Omega T plus V naught
over Omega n sine of what it look like
so that's we've just got our you know we
see what it looks like but if you plot
the motion of this thing just us versus
time what's it look like and where does
phase angle come into it well this is
now X of T this is T equals 0 and this
undamped system essentially going to
look like that and this is the value X
naught the amplitude the initial
condition on X that you begin with and
right here the slope V naught is the
slope the initial slope of this curve
right because the time derivative is FX
dot if we were plotting X dot the
initial velocity is omega X naught and
so it's just the slope is V naught here
so it this is your initial velocity this
is the and I didn't yeah that's right
this is the initial displacement the
totally clique total written out
mathematically it looks like that and
I'm plotting this function a cosine
Omega t minus fee yeah I see Hinda I
just you I was just looking at myself
and says can't be right
this has got to be the initial condition
on X and this has to be the initial
condition on V and whatever this turns
out to be this whatever turns out to be
the after you have some initial velocity
you have some initial displacement the
system can actually peek out sometime
later at a maximum value right and that
maximum value is bad so this is this
over here this is the square root of x
naught squared plus v-0 over Omega N
squared square root that's what the peak
value is and this system is undamped so
it just goes on forever so the question
is though what is this gap here between
when it starts and when it makes its
maximum well you can when you we use an
expression like we said we can express
this as sum a cosine Omega t minus V
it's just the point at which the cosine
then reaches its maximum so if this axis
here is Omega T if we plot this actually
versus Omega T then one full cycle here
is 2 pi or 360 degrees so if you plot it
versus Omega T then this gap in here is
just see that's the delay in angle if
you will lose the system
goes through between getting from the
initial conditions to getting to the
peak of the cosine so and fee must also
then be equal to some Omega n times a
Delta Tau I'll call it some time delay
so if I plot if this is plotted that
this axis is time not Omega T but time
then the same plot the same plot this
delay here this is a delta this is a
time delay and this is when you plot it
against time it's a delay in time to get
to the peak and Omega n delta tau this
delay must be equal to the phase angle
so the delta tau this time delay is feed
over Omega and so you can think about
this as a delay in time or as a shift in
phase angle depending on whether or not
you want to plot this thing as a
function of Omega T or as a function of
time but we're going you're going to use
in need that's concept of phase angle
the rest of the term I want to ask you
any questions about phase well the other
is the this because one of the things
doing because we're doing vibration for
the remainder of the term the this is an
introduction to a topic called linear
systems and so this is basically the
fundamental stuff that in which you then
when you go on to double of 4 which is
controls and that sort of thing this is
the basic intro to it ok and we'll talk
more about linear system behavior as we
as we go along
okay now we're going to do something
that you've much of this stuff I know
you've seen before some of the new parts
is just vocabulary and ways of thinking
about vibration that engineers do that
mathematicians tend not to so you have
seen most of the stuff before where 1803
right you've done all this and a year to
year a year ago last May I'm about in
May I taught the 1803 lecture with
professor Haines Miller now if you had
1803 last spring I think you had
somebody different but he invited me to
come in since same classroom and we
taught this we taught the second order
ordinary differential equation together
it was really a lot of fun he did it so
he said well here's how here's what we
do and then I said oh well Engineers
look at it the following way so I'll
give you what I'm going to show you is
what he and I did in class that day you
can go back and watch that on video it's
kind of fun but I'll give you my take on
it today so this is the engineers view
of what you've already seen in 1803 so
we have that system and we have that
equation of motion and the engineers and
mathematicians would more or less agree
to that MX double dot plus BX but I went
and looked at the webpage last night
last spring the person used C instead of
B pains Miller the year before use B so
the ever you can't you can't depend on
any absolute consistency but so let's
let's start off with our homogeneous
equation here and I'm looking out for
the response to initial conditions with
damping you've done this in 1803 you
know that you can solve this by assuming
a solution of form a e to the S key
plugging it in gives you a quadratic
equation that looks like s squared plus
s B plus K equals 0 this has roots
I am left out my am here so it starts
off looking like that you divide through
by the M s squared plus B over m s plus
K over m equals zero and that's where
Hanes would leave it and he'd give you
the entire answer in terms of B over m
and K over m and that kind of thing
engineers we like to call that the
natural frequency squared and this terms
we modify to put it in a terminology
that that is more convenient to
engineering so I'll show you where that
how that works out when you solve this
quadratic just using the quadratic
equation you get the following you get
the roots
you get that the roots there's two of
them I'll call s1 and to the roots to
this equation look like minus B over 2m
plus or minus square root of b squared
over four M squared minus K over m and
that's you'd get that's what you'd get
do in 1803 and an engineer would say
well let's change that a little bit so
my roots that I would use for s one and
two I just factored out this is fits K
that's Omega N squared I can factor that
out and comes Omega n on the outside and
I put in Omega n in the numerator and
denominator here as well so I get roots
that look like
I've just manipulated that a little bit
I have a name for this term use the
Greek letter Zeta as B over 2 Omega and
M the way I remember it my brain it's
called the damping ratio
okay and if I say that then the roots s
1 & 2 for this look like minus Zeta
Omega n plus or minus Omega n times
square root of Zeta squared minus 1
those are the roots that vibration
engineer would use to describe this
second order linear differential
equation solution homogeneous solution
okay those are the roots of the equation
and when you have no damping then this
term goes away and you're left with and
I left an eye out of here I think no I'm
fine the eye comes out of here okay
so for one thing to absolutely take away
from today is to remember this that's
our definition of damping called the
damping ratio when that's one it's a
number we call critical damping not sure
what that means in a second and what
credit when it's greater than one you
will system won't vibrate it just has
exponential decay if it's less than 1
you get vibration and that's why we like
to use it this way as if meaningful its
value instantly no it's greater or less
than 1 it's going to change the behavior
of the system from vibrating to not
vibrating ok so now there's four
possible solutions to this I'm not going
to elaborate on all of them but they D
equals zero we've already done know the
answer to that response to initial
conditions simple we know that one you
have another solution when Zeta is
greater than one Zeta is greater than
one this quantity here is inside 2
greater than one so it's a real positive
number and this is that all the both
roots of this thing are completely real
ok and you know that they remember the
response if we hypothesize in the
beginning that response looks like some
a e to the st so now we just plug back
in this is our s key values we can plug
them back in and we will get the motion
of the system back so for greater than 1
st comes out looking like minuses Zeta
Omega n T plus or minus square root of
Zeta squared minus 1 times T and you
just plug this in and X is just e to the
st but these are just pure real values
and you'll find out that the system from
initial conditions on velocity and
displacement just as
and dies out Zeta equals to 1 then st is
just - you get a double root - Omega NT
twice and the solution for this like an
arrow right out the whole thing X of T
here is just some a 1 plus T a to e to
the minus Zeta Omega n T and again it
looks it's just some kind of damp not
very interesting response no
oscillations and then finally Zeta less
than 1 and this is the only one this one
produces oscillation and the solution
for s T is plus or minus - is Zeta Omega
and T a real part plus or minus I Omega
and T times the square root of 1 minus
Zeta squared now I've turned around this
Zeta squared minus 1 this is now
negative number square root a negative
number gives me I and now I turn this
around so this is just a real positive
number so when you get I into this
answer what does it tell you that the
solution looks like sines and cosines
right so now this gives you sines and
cosines with a decay this is an
exponential to eat in the minus Zeta
Omega and T multiplied by a sine and the
cosine and so this is the interesting
part so the most of the work of the rest
of this term we only interested in this
final in that solution and what it looks
like for this one
mm-hm
so for Zeta less than 1 X of T some a e
the minus Zeta Omega n T times a cosine
Omega DT I get de times t minus the
phase angle come out looking like that
and if you draw it depends on initial
conditions so again a positive velocity
and a positive displacement it does this
but then it dies out so it's very
similar to the undamped case except that
it has this damped damping causes that
die out with time but this right here
this is still the initial slope is V
naught and the initial displacement here
is X naught
and I'll give you a lime going to give
you the exact expressions for this and
we'll talk about it another way of
writing this then in terms of the
initial condition is this looks like X
naught cosine Omega DT plus v-0 over
Omega D
okay so expanding this out this result
clearly has to depend on the initial
displacement and on the initial velocity
now what's this I keep writing this
Omega D so notice in here in the
solution it's Omega n times the square
root of one minus theta squared so the
frequency that's in here isn't exactly
its Omega n its Omega n altered by a bit
Omega sub D is called the damped natural
frequency and it's equal to Omega n
times the square root of 1 minus theta
squared okay the system actually
oscillates at a slightly different
frequency and for most systems that
vibrate at all this damping term is
quite small and when you square it it
gets even smaller so this is usually
this is a number that's like 0.99
oftentimes or even bigger than that this
is very close to one for all small
amounts of damping but being really
careful about this including it
everywhere that's what this result looks
like and this little thing sigh this
little phase angle here is tangent
inverse of Zeta over the square root of
1 minus Zeta squared and this number
turns when when damping is small this is
a very small number and most of the time
problems that we deal with the damping
will be small so let's say for
small damping by that I mean Zeta say
less than ten percent what we call 10
percent 0.1 and if you want to if you
have a little more you know to you don't
care too much about the precision it
might even be twenty percent what's
actually if it were point 2 squared is
0.04 right one - 0.04 point 96 square
root point 98 so even with 20 percent
damping the difference between the
undamped natural frequency of the damped
natural frequency is 2 percent so for
most for most cases with any kind of
small damping at all we can write an
approximation which is easier to
remember and it's all I carry around in
my head I can't remember this quite
frankly don't try to and I would instead
express the answer to this as just an X
naught cosine Omega D T plus V naught
over Omega D sine Omega damped times
time times e to the minus 2 Zeta Omega n
T so why do I bother to carry the mega
DS along if I just said that they're
almost exactly the same for light
damping that Omega is approximately make
a D well you need to keep this one in
here because even though it's only 2%
difference at 20% damping if you say the
solution is Omega n when it's really
Omega D there'll be a this this thing
will accumulate a phase error over time
so that it gets bigger and bigger this
error here
because you haven't taken care of that
little 2% that 2% can bite you if you go
through enough cycles okay so we keep a
keep Omega D in the expression here but
other than that it's almost exactly the
same expression that we just came up to
for the simple response of an undamped
system to initial conditions X naught
cosine plus V naught over Omega n sine
and now all we've added to it is put the
transient decay the fact that it decays
into the expression and change the
frequent natura the frequency it
oscillates that to Omega D instead of
Omega n
so I'm going to try to impress something
on you if I took this pendulum and my
stopwatch
measured the natural frequency of this
thing I could get a very accurate value
if I'd do it carefully then I take the
same object and I don't get them in
water and it goes back and forth and the
conspicuously goes back and forth but
dies down now after a while because it's
got that water damping it but I measure
that frequency and it's you know it's
ten percent different twenty percent
different I have and I've seen people
make this mistake dozens of times you
say that's the experiment explain why
what's the reason that that measured
frequency has changed getting ocean
engineers in the audience all right so
why does the if you put the pendulum in
water and still oscillate now so it's
got its it isn't so damp that it's okay
so it's got some damping it's dying out
and the natural frequency is changed by
fifteen or twenty percent what's the
explanation and the answer you always
get from people is damping why because
everybody's been taught this thing right
and they all then assumed that the
change in the frequency is caused by
damping but damping couldn't possibly be
the reason because with 20 percent
damping this single died out about two
swings and it's done that's a lot of
damping actually but it only accounts
for two percent change in natural
frequency not 15 hmm so what causes the
change in the frequency
no not buoyancy that could that that
could actually have an effect that's
actually it I should say yes you're
partly right
isn't even it there's another reason
when the thing is swinging back and
forth there in the water it actually
carries some water with it effectively
the kinetic energy you now know how to
do vibration problems finding the
equations of motion accounting for the
potential energy and the kinetic energy
the kinetic energy changes because some
water moves with the object and it's
called added mass it literally there's
water moving with the object that has
kinetic energy associated with the
motion and it acts like it's more
massive it is dynamically more massive
as water moving with it
okay so trying to impress on you that
damping doesn't cause much of a change
when in systems that actually vibrate
really here to observe the vibration if
you can observe the vibration damping
cannot possibly account for a very large
shift in frequency
okay what's the motion look like a
little bit here
so that's what this solution looks like
we know it depends on initial conditions
the the distance from here to here will
make this a time axis this is one period
so this is tau D that's the damped
period of vibration and we know that X
of T is some a e to the minus Zeta Omega
n T cosine Omega DT minus a phase angle
we can write that expression like this
and this term this is just a cosine this
term repeats every period right if it's
at maximum value here exactly one period
later it's again at its maximum so the
cosine term goes to 1 every 2 pi or
every period of motion all right so I
want to take I'm going to take the I'm
going to define this as the value of at
X at some time T I'll call it T naught
and out here is X at T naught plus n tau
D n periods later so this is a period to
find this period remember
Omega D is the same thing as two pi
times the frequency and Hertz and it is
and frequency is one over period 2pi
over the period so remember there's a
relationship that you need to remember
now that relates Radian frequency to
frequency in cycles per second and Hertz
to frequency expressed in period right
this would be tau D here and this would
be an F D all frequency that's a for any
frequency you can say that Omega D is 2
pi Omega is 2 pi F is 102 pi over tau so
you've got to be good with that but now
so here we are two peaks separated by n
periods and I want to take the ratio of
X of T to X of T plus n tau D here and
that's just going to be then my when I
take that ratio X of T has cosine Omega
DT minus V in it and n periods later
exactly the same thing appears right so
the cosine term just cancels out this
just is e and the A's cancel out that's
the initial conditions it's e to the
minus Zeta Omega and T and I guess I
call it t naught over e to the minus
Zeta Omega n T naught plus and damped
periods if I bring this in the numerator
the exponent becomes positive the T
naught terms minus Zeta Omega and T
naught plus those cancel and this
expression is just e to the plus Zeta
Omega
n times n T D and the last step that I
want to do to this I'm what I'm coming
up with is a way of estimating purpose
of doing this does this transient curve
we know depends on this is controlled
you know by damping by Zeta I want to
have an experimental way to determine
what is data and I do it by computing
something called the logarithmic
decrement so if I take the natural log
of X of T over X of T plus n periods
it's the natural log of this expression
so it's just the next I just get the
exponent back this then is n Zeta Omega
I guess better to do it carefully mega n
n tau D but tau D is a 2 PI over Omega I
get some nice things to cancel out here
so this natural log over the ratio this
is n Zeta Omega N and this is two PI
over Omega D which is Omega n times the
square root of 1 minus Zeta squared
Omega ends go away and for Zeta small
this term is approximately 1 in which
case this then becomes n 2 pi Zeta and
Zeta equals 1 over 2 pi n natural log of
this ratio of X of T over X of T plus
and T
so experimentally if you just go in and
measure your in you plot out the
response you measure a peak value you
measure the peak value and periods later
compute the log of that ratio divided by
one over two pi n the number of periods
you have an estimate of the natural
frequency estimate of the damping ratio
scuse me okay so I'm going to give you
one quick little rule of thumb here so
this is a experimental way that very
quickly you can estimate the damping of
pendulum or whatever by just doing a
quick measurement
so if it happens that after n periods
this value is half of the initial value
then this ratio is 2 right so X of T
some end periods later this is only half
as big this value is to the natural log
of 2 is some number you can calculate so
there's a little rule if you just work
that out you find that Zeta equals 1
over 2 pi and 50% not 1 times Well
natural log of 2 you end up here with 0
do this carefully 1 over 2 pi n 50%
natural log of 2 and that is 0.1 1 over
n 50% that's a really handy little
engineer tool to carry around in your
head so if I have an oscillator this
will end here I can do an experiment
give it an initial deflection and and so
you know it starts off at 6 inches or
three inches amplitude and you let it
oscillate until you see it die down to
half of that value so let's say about
four cycles this thing decays by about
50 by 50 percent okay 4 cycles plug 4
into that formula you get about 0.025
agreed two and a half percent damping
really very can be little thing to carry
around with you measured pendulum how
much damping is if have a now this is
why
saying most things that have any
substantial amount of vibration the
damping is going to be way less than 10%
if it dies if it takes one cycle - for
the amplitude to decrease one cycle for
the amplitude to decrease by 50% how
much damping does it have 11% so 11%
damage a lot of damping the thing starts
out here and the next cycle it's half
gone and the next cycle after that it's
half of that and soon about three cycles
it's gone so if you see anything that's
vibrating any length of time at all its
damping is way less than 10% and this
notion of small damping is a perfectly
good one
now I'll then I'll close by just saying
one other one other thing if something
vibrates a lot the damping small is that
you if you don't have if you don't if
you have you need small damping for
things to actually vibrate very much
this thing this is vibrating that
high-pitched one that's about a
kilohertz how many cycles you think it's
gone through to get down to fifty
percent of that initial amplitude that
you could hear few thousand how much
damping do you think this rod has really
tiny really tiny okay all right so even
though all we talked about today was
single degree freedom oscillators hope
you learned a few things that will carry
now through the rest of the term we use
all this these concepts that we did
today to talk about more complicated
vibration good luck on your to Double L
one quiz see you on Tuesday
you